we've all played hide and seek when we
were kids but some of us were more
successful at hiding than others wait
until you see some of the biggest
hide-and-seek fails including some that
are unintentionally terrifying don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
give this video a big thumbs up if you
got scared now let's get to the 20 kids
who are absolutely terrible at
hide-and-seek this cutie this is
probably the cutest thing you've ever
seen kids have the strange hide-and-seek
theory because they think that if they
don't see people people can't see them
either we wish it would work this way
this little adorable girl hid in the
bathroom but instead of finding some
interesting places she just covered her
eyes with the bathroom towel sure it's a
good idea in theory but in real life
this just won't work kid although we
have to admit that she's completely
adorable so her hide the seeking
abilities are totally excused and trust
us it'll only get better
peekaboo seriously you can tell some of
these kids wanted to come up with the
best hiding spot ever a Lego box that
could work but this kid really
underestimated her size compared to the
box still her intentions were there okay
we want to know if she was actually
surprised how her parent was able to
find her so quickly this one is quite
clever but sorry kid you can't fit in
tiny boxes anymore she'll have to find a
bigger Lego box if she'll want to hide
it and trick people they're really
growing up so fast aren't they boxed up
now this kid had the right idea when it
comes to hide and seek if you want to
hide somewhere you at least have to find
the right size box right so he
definitely gets a bonus point for at
least thinking he's going to be in the
right direction with his hiding spot but
here's the part the kid didn't quite
understand after you find the right size
box you also need to make sure it's not
see-through
seriously this one is actually really
clever but it has terrible execution
just imagine his poor face when you
realize that his seeking spot wasn't so
amazing after all two is better than one
but what's even better than a kid
totally missing the point of
hide-and-seek two kids totally missing
the point of hide-and-seek
seriously this one is such a fail it's
actually pretty funny it makes things
look even better because the kids look
like they're almost wearing the same
clothes this time the curtains a little
bit longer but it still didn't manage to
go all the way down to their toes to
truly hide them whose idea do you think
it was our money's on the kid on the
right and the
just played along a basket-case now this
is a true basket case seriously it just
kind of sad these kids just can't get it
right
this kid has the right idea even the
execution wasn't this bad except the kid
forgot to hide their legs underneath the
basket too maybe they were scared to
fully close it which is smart thinking
and they could probably get away with it
if their parents of the basket from the
other side but either way this is pretty
hilarious just look at those adorable
feet sticking out of the basket come to
think of it the kid probably took a nap
during this hide-and-seek game too kid
alligator
now we're talking this hide-and-seek
solution is one of the most amazing ones
we've ever seen and the kid could have
pulled it off but of course in practice
this just doesn't work it probably would
make more sense to use the alligator and
lay it down while hiding behind it but
this way is just much more entertaining
just imagine finding this in your room
and noticing the kids arms hugging the
alligator like this it's definitely not
a hide-and-seek case anymore but a hide
and scare case and this kid totally
nailed it this princess we're getting
there now this little princess well Thor
Prince had the right idea
sure hiding under a blanket works right
but you also need to make sure you're
actually laying down instead of just
randomly sitting this kid was probably
really disappointed when they realized
just how terrible their hiding place was
but they do get a bonus point because
this was actually really cute we just
hope the parent didn't laugh too hard
when they saw the strange blanket person
sitting on the bed you know what we'll
give them another bonus point because
the blanket is really cute and we really
love Disney can't see me here's another
example of a kid that thinks if they
can't see you you can't see them
this concept is totally adorable and it
definitely makes hide-and-seek more
hilarious but it's also really really
bad just look at this adorable child
he's standing behind a pole and he
thinks that's all he has to do to become
invisible how cute is this unfortunately
some kids have all the baby weight that
definitely makes it harder for them to
hide like this but good try though we
just hope he wasn't too disappointed
when his parent was able to find him so
quickly hide under the carpet
okay now this one is just ridiculous
this kid definitely didn't think this
through
sure lying underneath the carpet is cute
but it's definitely not a hide-and-seek
strategy you should employ well at least
if you don't want people to find you
it looks cute but seriously hiding under
the carpet and not only that the carpet
is clearly not big enough for this guy
this is a total fail and this kids
definitely terrible at hide-and-seek
he didn't even lie down he just lied on
his knees and hope for the best but he
does get bonus points because this is
pretty hilarious this fail okay it's one
thing to cover up your face during
hide-and-seek and think your parents
can't see you but this fail takes it to
a new level it's no longer just objects
it's also actual hands how adorable is
this these kids think that if they put
their hands over their eyes they won't
be seen by their parents it doesn't help
that they stayed together during
hide-and-seek either but they are
adorable and their outfits are awesome
so we have to give them some bonus
points don't worry it'll only get more
ridiculous now too adorable but first
let us show you something that will melt
your heart this one is just too cute for
words we've a feeling it's really cold
where this guy is
so this hide-and-seek technique is
totally suitable sure it might be
completely bizarre but you can't say
it's not too adorable for words check
this kid out to hide he simply put his
oversized winter hat over his head we
just hope he wasn't able to hide before
he did that and didn't take off running
after this hilarious technique either
way you have to admit that he's
completely adorable and deserve some
bonus points sort of got it now we're
getting there this kid also had the
right idea actually they kind of sort of
got it well until you realize that their
legs are still sticking out this is much
better than putting a box that's way too
small over your head it's also much
better than hiding under a clear box and
this could almost work because we could
barely see their little legs sticking
out from underneath the box if the
parent tried to find them from the other
side this kid would have definitely won
but still you have to admit that it's
still a pretty terrible hiding spot
these geniuses in case you're wondering
yep we're still playing hide and seek we
told you these kids are really really
terrible at this game imagine telling
your kids to hide coming to the kitchen
and seeing two figures standing
underneath a blanket this is another
example of Haydn's scare because it
could have ended up in a pretty scary
situation but no it's just kids that
really don't know how to play hide and
seek
seriously it's even worse that they
decided to hide together here's the
first hide-and-seek lesson kids
never
hide in pairs because it really never
works out the way you want to closet the
never hide in pairs rule also applies to
these two cuties these two got the right
idea but then they totally ruined it by
not climbing in the closet and actually
closing the door behind them
perhaps they realize they are actually
really afraid of closets either way this
sort of thing makes hide-and-seek a
really easy game so always remember the
rules to not being found find a hiding
spot actually try to hide and tell your
sibling to go somewhere else seems
simple right well not if here this next
kid bathroom do you remember the very
first bathroom photo we showed you the
little girl hidden behind a curtain in
an attempt to hide but it barely covered
her eyes well this kid is definitely
better but not that much better the kid
used the bathroom step to make sure he's
totally hidden and this time the curtain
was actually long enough to cover most
of his body but yet you could still
clearly see he's there and so we can
only give him half a point for his
creativity this could have easily fooled
us if it wasn't for that hand trying to
close the curtain hide and feet what is
it with these kids in hide-and-seek are
they really this scared to fully close
the door do they not know that that's
how you lose the game we've already seen
the two kids and their attempt at hiding
in a wardrobe but this is way better
than that although it is pretty adorable
to see these tiny feet sticking out from
the cupboard it's even better when you
realize that he's actually so small he
could probably fit inside the cupboard
or maybe he realized he couldn't and
that's why his feet are sticking out
either way this is not how you play hide
and seek Lego fort okay this one is just
too adorable for words
what's better than hiding in a closet a
cupboard or under the carpet
how about hiding in an epic Lego fort
this kid seriously had the right idea
but of course you also have to make sure
that this fort is actually fully
enclosed otherwise your parent could
easily see you if they come from the
side so while we're definitely giving
this kid some bonus points the execution
of the idea is still pretty terrible of
course it is because if it was good it
wouldn't be in our video anyway lamp kid
we've showed you poles carpets
transparent boxes and more but what's
even better than hiding behind a pole
and thinking nobody can see you hi
behind a lamp and thinking that would
ever work seriously what was this kid
thinking was he channeling his inner
lamp because that definitely doesn't
work if you want to play hide and seek
well it doesn't work if you want to win
hide and seek anyways but our final two
hide-and-seek techniques are way better
than this one both almost figured it out
but their execution is absolutely
hilarious getting there if you thought a
transparent basket was bad wait until
you see this we actually feel really bad
for the kid because he still did way
better than some of the other kids we
showed you today finding the right size
blanket check fitting in perfectly check
what this kid didn't think about was the
fact that this laundry basket has holes
on each side you can totally see where
he is although we have to give the kids
some credit because unless the parent
had fantastic eyesight they still
wouldn't be able to see this kid through
the holes either way this is still
completely hilarious the Shadowhunter
some kids definitely fail hiding behind
the curtain but this kid was totally
betrayed by nature we can't even blame
him imagine coming up with a fantastic
hide-and-seek plan to hide behind the
curtain that's actually long enough but
then the son betrays you because you
actually have no idea your shadow is
visible this is also one of those hide
and scare moments because we have a
feeling the parent was totally freaked
out before they realized that it's
actually their kid hiding behind the
curtain
poor child you have to admit that it's
still pretty hilarious though and that's
all for our video what's the scariest
toy you ever heard of let us know in the
comments thanks for watching we'll see
you next time
[Music]